ترى الصوره كامله تلك ورقه حماس حين ترد
عبر الوسطاء على مقترح
باريس لا ترى الحركه في الامر مجرد هدنه
اخرى او صفقه تبادل جديده لذلك وغيره
تعاملت الحركه كما تقول مع مقترح اتفاق
الاطار بروح
ايجابيه قدمت الحركه ملاحظاتها بما يضمن
وقف اطلاق النار الشامل
والتام انهاء العدوان الهمجي على المدنيين
العزل من اطفال ونساء وشيوخ وادخال
المساعدات والمواد الاغاثه وتامين الايواء
للنازحين وضمان الاعمار ورفع الحصار عن
قطاع غزه وانجاز عمليه تبادل
الاسرى لقد تعاملت الحركه مع المقترح بروح
ايجابيه وذلك رغم ردود الفعل الصهيونيه
التي حاولت القفز عن ابسط حقوق شعبنا في
هذا
الاطار هي محاوله ايضا في الجانب
الاسرائيلي للقفز على الحدث مع اقرار
باستمرار المفاوضات نفي نتنياهو الالتزام
باي وعود في الصفقه المطروحه ارفقه
باصراره على المضي في حرب بد له ان تحقيق
اهدافها هي مساله
شهور نحن في طريقنا الى النشر المطلق
النصر في متناول ايدينا والامر ليس مساله
سنوات بل مساله اشهر فقط ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يصنع العجائب ويتقدم بطريقه
منظمه لتحقيق جميع اهداف الحرب التي
طلبناها
منه هو الانغماس اذا اكثر في الحرب
الداخله شهرها الخامس تلك التي يتهم عضو
مجلس الحرب بيني جانس رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو بانه يضر باهداف فها
ويماطل ويتيح لحماس ترميم قوتها
وسلطتها هذا واحد من خلافات تتصاعد في
مجلس الحرب الجات نتنياهو كما يبدو الى
التمسك بموافقه حكومه الطوارئ اولا حيث
يستقوي باليمين المتطرف على اي قرار بشان
المقترح الجديد وكما انه يرفض الاستماع
لاصوات شركاء الحرب فانه يقاوم ضغوط
واشنطن التي راجعت مفرداتها وصارت تتحدث
عن هدنه ممتده بل ان وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي وجد في رد حماس مساحه تساعد في
الوصول الى
اتفاق اتيحت لنا الفرصه اليوم لنناقش مع
الحكومه الاسرائيليه رد حماس على الاقتراح
الذي قدمته الولايات المتحده وقطر ومصر
لاعاده الرهائن المتبقين الى وطنهم وتمديد
الهدنه الانسانيه وعلى الرغم من وجود نقاط
غير موفقه بشكل واضح في الرد فاننا نرى ان
هناك مساحه للتوصل الى اتفاق وسنعمل على
ذلك بشكل
متواصل يتحدث بلينكن ايضا عن امور لا يمكن
قبولها لكن الرد يتيح في رايه فرصه للمضي
بالمفاوضات وعن التفاوض عينه يقول مسؤول
الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه انه ناقش مع
الاسرائيليين في خامس زياره له للمنطقه
منذ بدء الحرب على غزه الجهود الاخيره
لضمان اطلاق سراح جميع الاسرى المحتجزين
لكن انتوني بلينكن اسمعهم ايضا تاكيدا على
اهميه اتخاذ كل الخطوات لحمايه المدنيين
في غزه وكذا اهميه زياده حجم المساعدات
الانسانيه للنازحين منهم في جميع انحاء
القطاع